good afternoon everybody welcome once
again it's Wednesday afternoon and we
are the EMU a based Android developer
relations team and Google TV team here
to talk to you about Android development
I'm Sparky coming to you from Munich
Germany and we've got Matt and Nick and
rich in London UK and who is this worth
face that we see yeah hi that we have a
guest with us in the UK office again
this week this week it's Chris Bane's my
guys just I trying to say
size three minor yeah so some of the
stuff so a couple three fresh library of
wrote Frank castor all sorts bit alike
really and that means
general awesome in the Android community
over here so yeah going up so we're
hoping quite a lot of you join in today
because we really three questions in the
moderator for this week if not it'll be
quite a short session so if you have
Android development questions please
come along and join us in the Hangout or
comment on the G+ thread if you can't
get in and we'll that will invite you in
so you can ask your questions live
else answer more questions into the
moderator to to keep us going
questions I'm impressed that's a 50%
improvement over the last time I looked
two questions and one thing that says
this is not a question but enjoy your
hangout thanks Andrew Kelly when he's
not adding questions into the moderator
Easter day was saying welcome to
Australians not organised by Google is a
community relevant anyone considered
petroi Khan so yeah I hope we can
introduce you to the joint organizers if
you want to get a you know George Kondo
I believe they did have to license the
name I'd see I thought George Coleman
wasn't organized by essential thing it
was dish you like at what people could
do it and then now they're discussing
that maybe they should make it a
slightly more sort of collaborative
effort so that you have to kind of go
answer any comments any of the drug come
on nicely watching this the airframe
yeah everybody knows pop in tell us that
sheet so we stop guessing that's just
dangerous you'll see hey there good to
see you again
thanks for joining do you have any
questions for us today I hope you can
hear me now yeah okay I just wanted to
ask about implementing or using Google
Hangouts API inside an Android
application and what are the baseline
guidelines for that and so on yes that
doesn't exist
have you found something we don't know
about no we're thinking to buy to build
an application and try to see if there's
an API for hangouts also for Android not
only for web didn't found in so I just
wanted to ask you know I mean the people
you should head to the Google Plus
office hours
they host office hours as well as
developers.google.com slash live and
have a chat with them they might be able
to talk to you about any API is that
there are hangout moment I think the
hangouts API is around any functionality
to hangouts not that's almost muted you
say Wells out where's out starting when
you need it
oh of course hands off who yeah he got
his first booyah agua during the week
yeah if you're watching out enjoy that
right I'm just going to pull up the
comments thread as well just to make
sure we don't miss anything we got Paul
and we got Stephano well guys do you
have anything on your mind you'd like to
bring out
any Android related topics they'd like
to talk about now hello can you hear me
okay April hi yeah good to meet you guys
a week ago yeah you today it was good
good fun and good to see what's going on
with Android I do have one quick
question I can't remember aspects of
somebody I can't member who it was about
submitting the NFC fix as a patch can
someone tell me where to go or what to
do please
yeah if you go to source.android.com yep
there's a section there about how to
submit a change okay cool sounds easy
then I'll have a look at it anyway
later on thank you very much any other
questions hang out what's on your mind
hello I am an Italian student speak
English only an app for Android it's
just a benchmark okay what sort of a
benchmark like performance I are you
doing native code or like web
performance or Java when I got the phone
mats Sabich okay cool so how long how
long have you been working on it about
FEX
okay so so what's your what's your
impression of Android is a development
platform do you have any favorite api's
or something that you wish that we would
fix oh so what what parts about Android
do you like working with and what parts
about Android you think maybe
you would like to see some changes in
for me Android is perfect at the moment
yeah it's very good okay
very well said I'll send you your money
later cool okay you stop dating a couple
of threads to make sure everybody knows
where the moderator and where this this
sessions actually and today we take a
look at some of the moderator questions
buggy sure there's not a whole lot here
as I said the first one's kind of
interesting this one's from our friend
Johan in the Netherlands says he wants
to create two skins for the app which he
equates to having different resources
and he wants to basically know what are
best practices for doing this should he
create a library project with then two
different sets of resources or you know
sort of riff on now and just as an aside
he also mentions that he's using maven
to build it in case that makes a
difference
responses from Andrew Kelly and Yossi
suggests using themes but I'm thinking
maybe I mean you know what if he doesn't
want the assets for both branches of the
app in the same binary you know in same
apk like maybe one is for a client or
something like that okay Frank Oz has
scored multiple themes how did you go
about that and yeah so all the graphics
were in the same apk so yours all of
them on styles and themes we've custom
attributes so have you said it ages for
Sophie yeah so in your activity before
you call super done create it's probably
before and you call set style that's
also safe family yeah so you call that
with your the story you want so you call
it so we change it off a preference or
whatever you need to do so you if you
change though you have to recreate
activity no does it so as long as you
call set style before you call super
done create or works you call it after
laughing time
okay so you're studying dynamically
you're dynamically switching your theme
basically the the drawable resources
that compose your theme right at an
instantiation of the activity then yeah
yeah so you'd have to do that for each
activity you can do that I'm not gonna
happen
yes but if you create a base activity
yeah oh six ten from all it all works
good so this is going to depend on
whether he wants to have an app which
can change themes on user requests which
restart the activity and change it and
put both sets of themes in the apk
whether yeah you're trying to reskin the
same application for multiple clients
and you don't want all the resources in
both in which case the library project
would be a great way to go
downloadable skins like beautiful
widgets or something like that yeah what
about just like do you know how they
organize their there are themes there
are they plugin for widgets light
download into the SD card and then they
load the images via Fred and then just
sit the drawables on each view and to
sort of manually write so they're not
using the resource framework they're
just using drawables there are apps so
all the apps where the themes are
downloaded via google play they're done
by resources so I think you can access
external resources there package manager
if I remember rightly mmm but I've never
done it self coming next week yeah I
know I've seen apps on other platforms
where it was you know you could have
these these skins and it was very
important that your resources be
numbered with exactly the same
identifiers as in the base project so
funny one example where developers and
designers collide for the latest updates
the ultimate stopwatch Marie wanted to
change the theme as he went through to
the countdown but of course that would
require it was it was in a few pages so
you could swipe across the countdown but
required restarting the activity to
change the theme which I didn't find a
solution around unfortunately yeah but
the action bar I have tabs in it and
drop down overflow and button
I didn't really know that so we didn't
happen the only kind of thing that I've
done remove you like this is the
scenario you have multiple clients one
thing you pretty much the same out of
the different themes and yeah the
library route is probably the best way
to go because you have to remember when
you're publishing to play store you need
a different package name to everyone
else so then yeah see you basically
understand doing that and they might
sell resources so yeah any sort of
comment I have nice okay hopefully
that's answered your question your head
I know you're gonna watch this a bit
later on sorry you've got some comment
Matt oh well you just gonna jump in
there yeah I was just gonna say so else
on a different topic but if you're
talking on this topic and wait for a
moment
okay on the four point two I'm quite
interesting this ability to log on to
this you know tablet or device for
multiple users can anyone show shine a
bit more light on that for example and I
presume the apps have their own data
areas for her user with things like
contacts and other things be users
specific as well yes yes yes you it's
very much like having your own
individual tablet sorry like everything
would be working in the same way as the
contacts and yeah the only thing that
shared are the application binaries
themselves so if if you download an app
and the one user the other user about to
see that same up downloaded into their
no no okay if they go to Google Play and
then try and install that the same app
they will install instantly it won't do
the download again okay so you just
copies itself in the like they don't
actually know if it's copying itself
we're just setting permissions or making
it linking it or doing something but if
yeah finder is yeah do you know what
about apps that download substantial
amounts of supplemental data you know
say like your game apps that have 400
bytes of resources that's going to
depend on that app itself and how
they've implemented that so if they yeah
Mike
I haven't tried it that's not quite sure
my guess is that it would have to
probably download that set of resources
again I don't actually know
well trying to get some recommendations
for you what did you find about that
issue sorry regarding the storage if we
were using an external storage is
caching for images or so on yeah each
user will we won't see the folder we
created for the different users because
basically today we're creating a folder
on the SD card get external storage and
then create an a folder for you know
lazy loading the images and so on yes so
an example is the gallery and the
cameras so if I go into one para file
and take a picture
it goes into slash SD card dicen
whatever it is puts it in there if I
switch users then I get a completely
different view of that folder and I can
take I don't see the the photos that the
original user took is it mountain volume
well this is all of our devices don't
have the external SD card of course so
that could be a different matter of
people releasing this with that I don't
have work at month does anyone know what
the security what security implications
is may have although they're in
different areas is it completely secure
in terms of from one but user to another
passed our knowledge of it at the moment
cuz we haven't tested out on any devices
that do have SD cards my guess is if
you've actually got an external sd card
and you're using this and you can still
take it out and read the space on it
that you'd be able to see each other's
data on the SD card but I don't actually
know there are no devices that support
that at the moment okay so try it out
and what do you mean by completely
secure I mean what is that what I mean
is from I don't mean bout external SD
cards I mean from one user to another in
terms of obvious if they can't see the
data they probably can't read it in any
other way outside of the app I believe
the intention is for the users to be
completely firewalled from each other
okay
the our sample use case as an enterprise
use case right where you've got to
enterprise users sharing one physical
tablet and realizing all these cases the
family coffee table you don't hand it to
your kids when it's logged into your
Gmail and your Twitter and everything
I'm sure if you turn on the encryption
to be tunnel encrypt storage or the
options called darlings increase the SD
image I'm guessing I don't know I'd be
interesting if you were encrypting stuff
on the SD card you'd have to use a
different key for each user and then of
that point apiece I seem to recall that
the the the coffee table model was
explicitly not one of the use cases that
we tried to optimize for in this
generation of the future because that
implies things like you know an
administrative user aka parent who is
who is controlling the account usage
experience of another user aka the child
and and that sort of management
infrastructure is not included
interesting yeah I am that's certainly
my use case for any way to keep my own
profile secure was the kids still get to
play their games and it's very easy just
to switch between the profiles
hand it over you've had that recently so
we've been joined by some new people
just say I was I was I was stunned the
other day to walk into the living room
and does
cover the the three-year-old had found
my Galaxy Tab taking him down unlocked
it started a game and actually been
playing the game all without any adult
assistance whatsoever like nobody told
her how to play this pain just started
there you go those skills these days
yeah welcome to the new guys who have
just joined us in the Hangout Leslie I
think it's Christian hey nice to see you
guys do any of you have any questions
for us oh yeah do you guys know how to
take a snapshot in code or follow this
screenshot code and now that I sure want
to do it and send it image across a
connection so do you mean take a
screenshot from code yeah it's the whole
device so just within your app the whole
device whole screen
oh no that's not possible I'd be a
security hazard if you had a service
ring in the background that can take
screenshots of the device you can take
screenshots of your own application yeah
yeah from the DBMS solution but it's
quite untidy here some thousands of
prices it's more for remote support
either it's a matter of showing us what
the user has against I have to guide
them through taking screenshots okay and
toss it but you have exercising on
samsung devices now so enough no in
which case I don't know a way Samsung do
have a screenshot but of their own so
maybe if you're talking to them you can
ask them about that yeah and guys know
yeah that don't use the thing good so
tea and it's all welcome to their API
and we don't want to use so she would
cost a fortune
okay questions right now
anybody else question how can we get a
mute for maybe excellent thank you we've
got a question a question from there we
go you can just speak it's okay yes well
actually that I have been working around
quite awful full-time over YouTube but I
wasn't I didn't participate
how did she see your name on the screen
what was your name my name is Maxie hey
Maxie
and what's your question so I have an
application in the market which uses
phone states and then obviously it won't
set the mission and it's I am imposing
new updates just this just yesterday try
to upload you an update and somehow
market tells me that it's now targeting
less devices where it's used to and
apparently is because it has said it's a
new permission there well it's not
manifest but the market shows that I
have a leads for log permission and it's
a severe situation in fact I don't show
you definitely asking for any
informations in the in the new apk
I'm not asking for that the mission
which has been edit it seems has been
added so the source of truth here is to
do use a apt so if you do a apt dump
badging and then the party or apk that
will tell you you know that will export
with missions because I'll show you
the implied permission some positions
are applied by others so it will
explicitly list out all the Commission's
Europe you are asking for so that's the
source of truth so if you can do that
anything it doesn't match up to what
you're seeing when you upload it to the
Play Store then that sounds like a bug
so you let us know if that doesn't match
up that's it okay I'll try it using that
so actually this a bit if I understand
correctly the situation is that that's
somewhat some of the libraries that I
may be using may be a question for my
permission is that correct
it could well be yeah well we don't have
to be in your manifest right I think the
can just imply you know it's not gonna
be a situation to me because I I don't
see that anything anywhere and it's
there yeah yeah
check your manifest and use a apt dumpy
magic yeah it's this thing is the way to
gets above this all right thanks cool
let us know how you get on I don't mean
to be joined by some new people as well
welcome to the house does anyone have
any Android developer questions let's
pick on somebody how about christian
christian and what's up you know if you
if you're not a mobile traffic where you
are now you're also welcome to to type
into the sidebar just click on the chat
if there's any new questions in the
moderator okay there is bring up with
trusty nexus 7
after uploading a new operation to
market to new permissions were
automatically done since I question
that's right this is this is actually
Maxim's question ok so this is this is
this is Mexico unless there might be
action by maybe in my help I want to him
love an action bar but in developer
console half of the users sure they're
still using two point three like create
two different apks no use
actionbarsherlock
yeah actually I'll show it's a great
solution for that it's exactly what it's
meant for it's very easy to add in and
works with the support library
fragmented everything thanks for waiting
Lucas asks a question about themes om so
no EMS have changed the default themes
that ship with so he says that assuming
that the options menu is black in
Gingerbread is not necessarily true on
all the devices how should you handle
this oh yeah this is a problematic and I
guess this is why we introduced holo and
styles which you can't modify so that
you can extend those cells no we're
gonna get the best advice is really to
use the built-in styles and themes so
you can use the things like and the
textiles like inverse and color primary
styles you can use so using those styles
that hopefully if it modified one of the
values everybody it's their library
although everywhere Josh Miller isn't
customizable they're fames is they
neither mop platforms that you not be
able to change anything that there are
hacks you can do but
Oh sis probably ask you about my conquer
that city yeah there was there's always
been a set of guidelines for system
icons and stuff like to replicate them
so anyways do try to stay with that feel
you're looking at the icon builder does
it only does one service yeah if you
start playing around with colored icons
and stuff and we're not really
recommending it then we're not
recommending for reason so yeah you're
gonna have a bad time next one hmm
what's that is there a right way to add
tabs to a multi pane view the he goes on
to say he was talking about doing two
pans where the right pane needs to have
tabs in it like the one in the Google
Play Store with a menu on the left hand
side actually Memphis pain never died
when I was obtained enough of mine I
decided not to go with tabs and I went
with dialogs instead and so he said if
I'm the right pane I just open a dialog
the other way to do it is for a library
called view page indicator so I'm
guessing that the right pane is in a
viewpager so you can use the indicator
to actually show where you are
it's not quite tab but it's near enough
that you could use it so me replicate
the top function in the right pane and
test the way I'll probably go with it so
it's good that's a good answer
we have myself I would probably I would
probably come out and just use the list
view I put the tabs in the action bar
there you go
to realize the chana's top left and then
Haney's
so what's it like a t-pain view and the
right pane
well as much swappable the changing see
a viewpager educates ET can't use pages
title strip you can use poast whole
strip yeah that was my because i page
table triplet yeah I triple have you
patient to get you lose anything trying
to bring up the store to see if I can
figure out what he's talking about but
I'm not really seeing this this right we
figured it's alright I think we can you
go statement droid nerd in Germany asks
is there possibility to find out the
home country overlooked in Google
account on Android we want to show
content based on the user's home country
the home country of being used for
display correct currencies to I don't
think the reason weighted by the country
I think the best way is probably to
query the locale of the device that's
the matter user setting not necessarily
physical presence yeah but you can check
the the IP address or something store
knows where you are
that's all servers detection that's not
your device you can check the sim
country as well so my advice would be
not to do any of this it would be to
respective iCloud the users sell the
device because that's you know the user
has control over these things like
currencies how they're displayed dates
how they're displayed and you try and
get a bit too clever then Amanda Lee
probably trying to implement a
recommendation of putting the cost of
their enough items into their
application yeah the location managers
yeah I was over in Mountain View Carlos
you see what you're set to UK image yeah
I think the countries so how do you find
out where the Play stores go return no
yeah yeah no that's not the case they're
asking but yeah yeah my suggestion would
be to stick the locale
and then if that's not their actual home
place as in let's say they they are from
Germany but they switch to English
British for some reason because that's
where they're more comfortable with then
give them the option to change it within
setting somewhere mm-hmm so cancer says
you ever I didn't use it as a default
essentially yes choose just try to be
clever once try to be clever and when
you get it wrong yeah but basically the
place or holds and checks the locale and
also checks the IP know from where the
device is chicken I mean there's there's
a couple of models like if you're if
you're offering like they just said you
know recommendations restaurants
shopping something like that then use
the location manager if you're offering
you know content that's kind of
spaceless like say you want to watch a
video and you want to know what language
to play the soundtrack in then use the
locale wait didn't I found since talking
to people at different countries is that
quite often they they don't necessarily
want to consume content in their native
tongue they quite often don't want the
dubbed version just a brief aside point
anyway so yeah you know I talked about
people about that because Germany is is
a country that's that's big enough where
you know Western condyles would the
entertainment content is almost always
dubbed into local language and the
consensus that I found among the people
that I've talked to here is that in fact
while there is a a small cadre of people
who always prefer in an original version
overwhelmingly most consumers do want to
talked into their language early that's
that's the case you know I think we
probably deal with the section bias of
people with open people yeah through
next question on the moderator asks if
there's any general tips for finding and
resolving an annoying unknown source of
battery drain
so I'm going to guess this a developer
question like you know you've got a
drain in your app not just generally my
device is running on battery or anything
like that I would say look at Trevor's
talk from from Google i/o where he's
giving the rundown on the the treat was
a traceview is that what it's called
yeah so my general advice is a couple of
them tours out there from some of the
silicon vendors or help you do this so I
think an arm has at all which will help
you track the power usage and so on
depending on which chipset your device
is running but generally my advice on
these issues is you're running down
power if you're powering coming up so if
you're keeping the screen on if you're
holding a wakelock
or if you're doing Network essentially
or the biggies so make sure you
understand your usage of those like
especially the way clock running wait
for location there was a presentation
done at roy cohn UK on dr power it's one
of the apps in the in the Play Store
that can help you with this and it does
something similar to the battery stats
but it does break it down in a lot more
detail so I was just looking at that now
and right there's third some good sort
of best practices like don't use say if
you're if you're doing networking don't
do polling if you don't have to if
you're you know if your data is coming
out sort of unpredictable times then
have a server side component that can
send you a Google cloud message you know
was he a synchronously or if you if you
are going to do polling don't use exact
alarms here is something like in exact
repeating alarms that will sort of
converge your wakeup times on to a few
selected intervals and then all of your
apps who are all using inexact repeating
alarms together can all be woken up at
the same time do the network and shut
back down again yeah alone I suppose
that's like don't do any work you don't
have to do as well so like things like
listening to this state event of the
battery and the network and adjusting
your behavior accordingly so if the
battery uses batteries under 20% then
maybe back off
appalling behavior and then also
aggressively or maybe you shut down a
certain receiver if you don't need it
like it's just do as little work as
possible so one of the things I quite
often see is people will use the boot
completed and listener to schedule any
alarms they might
to reset let's say for some pollen
behavior but the first thing they'll
doing the receiver is check whether
something should happen and if not just
pretend
where's you much better off actually a
dish using the package managed to
disable your big receiver if it's not
going to do anything when you do rather
than you know causing an extra like
piece of work to be done you know quite
a strenuous time when the system still
sign up there's lots of stuff going on
so it's just like popping in good
citizenry just don't do any work you
don't have to do any more questions for
inside the Hangout ok 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 he's not gonna get in but I will I'll
add him in anyway it's a new life
participants as well any questions from
people in the Hangout you said before a
man Pro last week yep hey Giuseppe any
question so you're just hanging out
oh we've got here you meet it if you
don't want if you're in a position where
you can't or don't want to talk then
feel free to type your questions into
the chat window
oh we do the question in coming from how
do we say this name ma Ryan that you
know Jim maybe marry ijn that's that's
touched it looks like meringue please I
am
no it is little Wednesday afternoon okay
I'll ask a question if you want no
basically when we're when you do a
search on the Play Store for a specific
developer you can see all the app you
can build all the tops is it is it a
good convention to show webview on my
app showing all the apps I have on the
Play Store maybe like Cover Flow or
something like that
yeah a reason why not like what often
people will just link out so that pops
your page on Play Store but if you
wanted to have more control over the
presentation then that's not a bad thing
to do I just say do it courteously to
your users like you know buddy put it
under you know if you have an about
screen pounds you can have like a get
more apps reversal something like that
mm-hm
I personally just yeah from the settings
menu from the overflow menu have a my
apps button take you straight to the
Play Store for the effort into designing
a yes it's one extra level there's one
publisher I'm thinking of who seems to
like to put up a splash screen where
they show you several ads of other
titles of their apps and then off to the
side a button that says you know click
here to play the game that you've just
launched it's not handy that kind of
that kind of I don't know it bugs me a
little bit like I want the title that I
selected to be very prominently
displayed and it would be nice if I
didn't have to have one extra click to
confirm the title that I just selected
and that's not overly aggressive to me
yeah basically what I wanted was to show
a selector on the settings or something
and show my app so option and then show
all the related apps to do that
developer yeah I mean if you wanted this
like and about us and and have a nice
murky with all of your offs on about us
that'll be great way to go okay I think
someone like and never looked at this
that day in beautiful widgets I think
they do quite a decent job of that so
margins come back again and he's drawn
us a picture of the the layout that he
was trying to build in this was not a
pain yes okay you just saw I'll just
show the picture to people inside so
we're gonna list view on the left hand
side on the right hand side there's a
fragment with a ListView inside it and
some tabs across the top just I think
what we were expecting to see and he has
commented to say hey would you mind
Chris made a quick Dorina for my
question I had the question about
multiplayer view terms I'm using
fragments
I need tant Android detail fragments
just like the Play Store but he doesn't
show although his question is and yeah
yes you can have few pages with list
views inside them without having
fragments and then the second fragment
would have tabs at the top which page
between er yeah yeah it would work if it
was simple enough why do the tabs need
to be in the fragment not question that
yeah why can't I just be any activity
because then it would cover the entire
set of the fragment yeah you want to see
them only on the right pane and not all
over the sky be you need that winglets
anyway like I don't think it's any
reason it has to be a fragment yeah you
could fight the tabs by noting a copy
the action bar show cool maybe a
fragment yeah and then it's just a view
holding the linear layout top would be
your tabs under that with a layout way
of one would be if refraining on your
side which is linear layer from this
yeah then taps in the Libyan lamp we
would be home so my mic is working again
yay so what I meant was is that on the
left side I have this menu which
displays a couple of data types on the
right side you have a couple of list
views in this particular case I have
three list use and because I need to
target both there you are because I need
to target both mobile phones and tablets
I wasn't natural enough to put those it
feels just on top of each other so I was
looking for a tab solution with the tab
to tell our top but it's somehow the tab
host isn't showing in my head so yeah at
least tap eyes don't use that works and
what's westeros it is been deprecated
now to use the action bar style tabs so
yeah using action bar or
actionbarsherlock but isn't that action
bar just use for so it has a system but
it won't kill do tabs in the in the
action bar and tablets rather than in
line say Betty you can you think all the
pages strip title which is in this is
pata Bertie library secretly so could
you type in the page title or yeah if
you use eclipse templates if you go if
you just generate a new project and
generate one with and swipe all tabs
it'll generate all the code you need
that's the best way to kind of like look
at how to do it okay so the layouts
covered for the swipeable tabs I could
just copy and paste in this case to the
friends yeah I'll show you how to do it
yeah thank you very much all right I got
a question for you guys
hey hey hey how's it going all right I
was gonna say yeah you guys should
recognize me maybe
well he's mad not nothing the hats yeah
well we got Deverell booth stuff going
on in Charlie's today so but I do have
an Android question I'm building an app
and I'm trying to use a service to
collect JSON data from a web service
Monge that data stick it into a database
and then make that data available via a
content provider to my main activities
what I've noticed is I'm able to fetch
the data without issue I'm able to parse
it standard JSON dump it in the database
the moment I try and access the data
from the content provider later and I'm
using the content provider from the
service as well to inject the data when
I try and use the content provider from
the activity I get nothing back from my
cursors if they're always empty I
thought that at first but these are very
very simple like I'm basically doing it
on one key it's like I have a YouTube ID
and it's just like give me the first
result that matches this ID maybe or
link if you're not calling a swap cursor
and you're on loadcomplete or something
simple like that swap cursor I don't
know about that one would explain a
little bit more sorry i easy loaders I
don't think so so you're just doing a
Content resolver doc query yeah if you
check that the dice is actually hitting
the database yeah yeah the data is in
the database what I did was I pulled the
MySQL data right from the device onto my
system and checked it out
and it's all there I just can the
service read it I can't of the content
provider again after it's written it in
no that's that's the weird part
once it goes in it doesn't want to come
out but when I try and do inserts of the
same data again I get database exception
stating that the yeah definitely let me
don't you on the reading of the data
back out if the date is in there and the
content is just saying there isn't any
maybe just mail through the all right
I'll send it to Matt today and you guys
maybe can take a look cuz I've been
stuck on it for a day or two and I've
got to get past this what did I do
I don't think I did maybe that is the
problem well though I thought I thought
there wasn't implied one base is the
implement a scouser as an extended space
columns do you remember influence the
only problem with that is you know the
YT player has stopped working oh yeah
that's because this certificates
probably expired Yeah right every every
year we have to regenerate our developer
certificates don't we this is the
YouTube player API it's set to expire
every two weeks after release because
it's not launched yet so yeah the API is
changing slightly because we didn't have
funds getting feedback to the YouTube
team are spending a lot of time kind of
tweaking it but they're also it's kind
of a fail-safe way and I'll really awful
way be sure no one publishes it's the
Play Store because then they change it
starts breaking so yeah I think it's
just their way of just making sure that
everything's kind of take along without
any problems it's coming like I think
they are lazy trying to get to that last
final step it is coming excellent thanks
guys I'm gonna go catch my bus
all right Chris because I will show you
guys later yeah no he's right okay
hi hey Ian yes yep the the epic a that a
apt to and well it it turns the list of
permission I would expect it to return
it knows all the permissions who died in
the hindered moon fest
and the market still shows different
lists and I'm sure it's the same file oh
can you host the apk somewhere like bit
on dry land and send us a link to it
so what should I used oh there's a chair
there you should use the chart just
notes of your I keep it in a comment to
the Hangout announcement on G+ not in
the chat comments because they they all
go away if you don't mind this routing
your
yeah first so because it's well it's
private so work with this turns what's
the name of the application can you
spell that you are new per another taxi
yeah oh cool nice actually it's a it's a
market noise yes it was in the market
before now so you've uploaded maybe
despite their yeah I do okay well we can
go it's now school reopens still should
I come back like mmm to the next office
hours so - and they see next you see
answer yes our next office hours will be
from dev ox so it's gonna be a slightly
different format now there'll be a lot
of Googlers making it next week the very
nice developer conference so it may be
taking a slightly different format next
week but it should be at the back at the
same time see we'll try and get back to
on the uber thing slightly separately
outside of the office hours all right
oh just in case out that way on the trip
it's
okay the problem with the chat is we
lose it as soon as the office hours goes
affair so in the modernity room
yeah yeah so we're in the thread or the
moderators fine okay
are you attending droidcon Netherlands
yes
Marnie we will be at droidcon
Netherlands on the see that I see you
there
Thanks do we have any more questions
coming through the moderator
spocky Thanks
is I'm only counting aids on there were
eight last time we answered one yeah
yeah still only eight I think we've all
okay okay is it possible to use the
YouTube API you already talked about so
it's come you see yeah they they were
taking beta testing but I'm not
convinced that's going on any more
because like I say they are kind of
getting to that final stages so I'm not
aware of any more developers getting on
board okay yep all right well if there's
no other questions today want me to wrap
it up a little bit early no sorry but
then it must be one of my question
please is yes I would like to know if
there is any wide the mid line for what
is permitted and what not let's suppose
for example that we would like to import
a video from another application okay
that has been done with another
application into the open application
and extract the audio from this video if
it'll move it is permitted from the
policy and if there is any policy about
would or not these are permitted what
can I find so I would very much depend
on the guidelines for that application
it's a bit of a strange use case but if
they're going to allow the share intent
send intent to share their video to
other applications and they're expecting
to send the video to social networks G+
Facebook etc and then it shares to your
application and your application then
pulls the soundtrack of it the use of
that soundtrack will be under the
guidelines of the application that you
said it in the first place I guess
certainly there is stuff in the content
policy isn't about not interfering
whatever apps data there is was true
they'd have to be it does sound you know
I think wishes are right the right here
is to make it easy for people to send
their content to your app rather than
going out and scanning yeah but cause
oblems the problem is that the data will
not be like was a senate would be
managed it would be shaded would be
expect something from inside so this is
the question the video application share
with me the video as is it but I am
extracting something from inside I'm
doing something wrong or can I do this
or I can do this this begins to sound
like more like I actually know the
problem the problem is that the content
that was shared with the my app but it's
not owned by the adapt but is honored by
the user so if there is some legal
action will be agonist the me and the
user but if the user won't the legal
action against me why he shave the the
subject with me I don't know if it's
clear the question button probably we
need a lawyer
to add YouTube content is a little bit
different because we know that the
YouTube we don't want that we manage the
files
probably they disease in their policy
but I am talking about a standalone file
that yes you might go around with
dialogues things like that just warning
the user not to use it for any bad
purposes as well make sure you only
heard up your own content or your any
you know you're not breaking any
copyright terms and conditions by using
this something something like at you
sure you want to want that we expect
about your from the video something
later no just a few just more down the
guard rule that only extract audio
stream videos that you might learn is
the right step mister okay thank you
gsfe cheap so we I think we had some
other people bouncing in and out during
that does anyone else have a question
that's salt okay yeah if there's no
other questions then we will wrap it up
thanks for coming everyone thanks being
crazy thanks for coming everyone
and as I say next week we'll be at
droidcon we hope very much to runs
excuse me come screen next week will be
a box very much beyond of the normal
time the more place but you do double
check on developers.google.com slash
live slash Android just in case we have
to shift the time to match some of the
double scheduling thank you all very
much and see you someone can shoot the
link over thanks very much